[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz cada
día hay terremotos de distintas
magnitudes en todas partes del mundo
muchos tienen lugar en el mar donde
terminan siendo imperceptibles pero a
veces sus epicentros suceden en pueblos
y ciudades como en Turquía y Siria donde
se produjo la última de las grandes
sacudidas de la historia todo tipo de
edificios se derrumbaron y decenas de
miles de personas han muerto las
imágenes son difíciles de olvidar y
demuestran la fragilidad del ser humano
pero también destacan la falta de
previsión y preparación de aquello que
en un principio no imaginamos pero
cuando sucede puede afectar a millones
de personas en esta edición echamos la
vista atrás y nos preguntamos Cuáles han
sido los terremotos más catastróficos de
la historia reciente de la Tierra
para encontrar el mayor terremoto de la
historia toca viajar hasta el 22 de mayo
de 1960 en Valdivia en el sur de chile
con una magnitud de 9,5 fue equivalente
a 20.000 bombas de Hiroshima alcanzando
mil kilómetros de Costa pueblos enteros
Fueron tragados por el mar cambió la
morfología del terreno y el cauce de los
ríos pero no sólo afectó a Chile hubo un
tsunami con olas que llegaron al otro
extremo del océano Pacífico alcanzando
Japón Hawai y filipinas este sismo fue
clave en el estudio geológico logrando
desde entonces poder estimar que un
megaterremoto así se repite cada 300
años sin embargo no fue tan mortal como
otros registrando alrededor de 2000
fallecidos
también en América en Alaska tan solo 4
años después el 24 de marzo de 1964 tuvo
lugar el segundo terremoto registrado
más grande de la historia con una
magnitud de 9,2 el centro y sur del
Estado quedaron completamente destruidos
y angulaites la capital hundida
parcialmente por fortuna era viernes
santo día festivo y la residencias de
estudiantes donde más personas se
acumulaban estaban vacías murieron
alrededor de 200 personas muchas por
ahogamiento
pocos fallecidos en lugares poco
poblados y de baja densidad para
encontrar el terremoto más mortífero
desde que se tienen registros hay que ir
hasta Haití en la isla de la española en
el Caribe el 12 de enero de 2010 un
terremoto de magnitud 7 a 15 kilómetros
de Puerto Príncipe provocó la muerte de
más de 300.000 personas el país más
pobre de América Latina empezó entonces
una crisis humanitaria que hoy todavía
perdura después de que millones de
personas lo perdieran todo
no es posible no es posible es como si
fuéramos ganado no somos ganado no somos
animales somos seres humanos no podemos
seguir así uno de los terremotos más
recordados de la historia reciente tuvo
lugar el 26 de diciembre de 2004 un
potente sismo submarino en el océano
Índico de 9,1 generó una serie de
tsunamis que afectaron a 14 países la
mayoría del sudeste asiático las
imágenes de olas tragándose distintas
costas dieron la vuelta al mundo
mientras alrededor de 230.000 personas
murieron muchas ahogadas por olas que
superaron los 30 metros en el mayor
maremoto de las últimas décadas también
en Asia un terremoto despertó las
alertas mundiales y cambió la forma en
la que los países occidentales se
relacionan con la energía nuclear el 11
de marzo de 2011 Japón sufría el
terremoto más grande de su historia con
un sismo de magnitud 9,1 alrededor de
22.000 personas murieron y más allá de
estas pérdidas países occidentales
entraron en pánico y se replantearon el
uso de la energía atómica el posterior
tsunami tras el terremoto golpeó la
central de fukushima causando un
desastre nuclear el más grande de la
historia tras chernóbil valorado también
en un siete sobre Siete en la escala de
accidentes de este tipo así lo vivieron
los días posteriores los sobrevivientes
la energía nuclear es lo más aterrador
incluso más que un tsunami el gobierno
el partido de gobierno los
administradores nadie nos dice a los
ciudadanos lo que realmente está pasando
hay un día en el que todavía hay cierta
tensión en Ciudad de México en 2022 en
2017 y en 1985 el 19 de septiembre
tembló en la capital de México
Precisamente en esa primera fecha se
produjo uno de los terremotos más
devastadores de la ciudad según la Cruz
Roja más de 10.000 personas murieron
después del sismo de magnitud 8 la
ciudad quedó devastada y se produjeron
grandes pérdidas materiales pero al
mismo tiempo surgió un movimiento social
que obligó a cambiar las normas las
construcciones se empezaron a hacer con
conciencia sísmica y se aumentaron tanto
los planes de prevención como la
formación de la población una elección
para todo el mundo que queda demostrada
en el menor impacto mortal que tuvieron
los siguientes terremotos en Ciudad de
Aunque tenemos que reconocer que diseños
de los sismos no existe una cultura
en la población y en el gobierno ante la
emergencia ante la posibilidad de otros
desastres no solamente sísmicos sino
contingencias de tipo ambiental
hidrometeorológicas en la era del
Progreso es fácil controlar todo tipo de
circunstancias pero aún cuando suceden
este tipo de desastres naturales el ser
humano se empeñece ante el poder de la
naturaleza y su indomabilidad sin
embargo ejemplos como el de Ciudad de
México demuestran que el compromiso y
responsabilidad de los estados pueden
ayudar a reducir los impactos de los
terremotos y evitar que imágenes como
las vistas en este programa se tengan
que volver a repetir como por desgracia
ha sido el caso de Turquía y Siria con
esto concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]